well in our mourning grounds the FDA is
expected to approve the first new class
of depression medication in decades it's
a nasal spray version of the drug
ketamine which is used in anesthesia and
powder form it is also the party drug
Special K dr. Jon LaPook joins us with
more good morning John
morning bianna more than 16 million
American adults suffer from major
depressive disorder about 30 percent of
them are treatment resistant they live
in pain that can be unbearable some are
so desperate they may actually
self-medicate with opiates or even turn
to suicide now a medication that's been
around for 50 years could give hope to
patients who could not find relief from
current antidepressants Kayla Snyder is
getting ready for an upcoming visit with
her family but less than a year ago she
couldn't even leave her apartment every
three to six months I seem to have a
severe depressive episode which includes
not getting out of bed for a week to two
weeks not showering not eating her
childhood in New Jersey appeared to be
happy but things began to fall apart
when Kayla left home for college I
didn't know what I was doing in life
what my purpose was I thought something
was wrong with me
antidepressants didn't help much and
over the next five years Kayla got so
desperate she tried to kill herself
three times then she started regular
intravenous ketamine infusions at this
New York City clinic which connected us
to Kayla I didn't have suicidal thoughts
every day which I used to have and I
just felt like a weight was lifted off
my shoulders traditional antidepressants
work on neurotransmitters such as
serotonin and norepinephrine that help
nerves in the brain communicate ketamine
targets a different one called glutamate
and works much faster than drugs like
prozac cymbalta or zoloft what we've
heard from patients who've gotten
ketamine is that wow this is what it
feels like to be normal and they never
thought they were gonna feel that way
again so it's very dramatic
dr. Dennis Charney was one of the first
to study ketamine infusion therapy and
would get a share of any profits from
the spray version ketamine
has been abused on the street where it's
called Special K how does it make people
feel there what the individual is
looking for when they take Special K is
a feeling of highness a out-of-body
experience and this in general is not a
major issue when you take the lower
doses that are needed to feel better
from depression each of Kayla's current
ketamine treatments cost four hundred
and seventy-five dollars and they are
not reimbursed by insurance if the FDA
approves the nasal spray version it will
likely be covered for Kayla that's
reason enough to see if it works just as
well as the infusions it really helps
your entire life not just oh let's get
high for an hour and then go back to a
depressing life it's more it changes
your life in a positive way this new s
ketamine spray called spray votto has to
be administered under a doctor's
supervision and is only for those who
have failed at least two antidepressants
dr. Charney says if antidepressants are
working for you stick with them but this
sounds really promising what are the
risks if any associated with the
ketamine spray well there can be a sense
of dissociation of over sedation blood
pressure and pulse can go up and of
course with any new treatment you've got
to follow it as there are more patients
who are being treated and see why there
any kind of new side effects we don't
know about and also see just how
effective it is and how often does a
treatment lasts well it's you know it's
it's been given in varying doses you
know it can be once a week it could be
twice a week as a spray and then
sometimes you have to keep giving it
week after week after week and it can
wear off so one of the things we're
gonna see is can you stop or do you have
to just keep giving it over time so you
know a lot of questions remain
unanswered but it is something for
people who are so depressed and they had
that feeling my patients who have had
that said it's like you're sinking to
the bottom of the earth and there's no
stopping you and one of the things it
does the antidepressants that work is it
gives you feet a bottom so you're just
not maybe it's not a happy pill but
you're not gonna sink lower than that
and that feeling of stability means a
lot to give people hope thank you John
always good to have you at the table